il benfica 7
quando ti invitano a parlare ad un
evento di questo genere devo dire sono
molto gentili ti dicono hai un tema in
questo caso era la creatività però vanno
anche un po più in là ti dicono diamo un
tema specifico così hai una mano insomma
e nel mio caso è come se il discorso si
fosse scritto da solo mi hanno guardato
e mi hanno detto alice oggi devi parlare
di scienza
io sono felice di parlare di scienza
perché in effetti amo la scienza e sono
contenta che siate qui con me a parlare
di scienza appunto un argomento non
troppo specifico ma ci siamo è quindi
quello da cui voglio cominciare oggi in
realtà è
l'opera di uno scienziato e vi voglio
sottoporre una serie di immagini che
rappresentano quello che secondo me è
uno dei più grandi scienziati della
storia
apriamo il file quarta superiore quinta
superiore storia dell'arte e ci troviamo
questa la cattedrale di rohan di claude
monet
una scienziata
monet è un impressionista è una corrente
artistica che si sviluppa nel corso
dell'ottocento in francia la conosce
aumentante in realtà perché è una
corrente particolare vuole rompere con
gli schemi tradizionali
dell'arte e dare qualcosa di diverso di
movimento e monet fa questo siamo nel
lui è un artista già abbastanza
affermato però non è che navighi
nell'oro e si dice ok voglio andare a
uomo perché tanti vanno lì perché tanta
e l'ispirazione quindi un giorno
passeggiando di fronte alla cattedrale
si sofferma sulla facciata
e la sua reazione non è una reazione
classica dell'arte perché non vuole
dipingere la facciata in maniera quasi
realistica vedutistica quello che
cattura a monet non sono i dettagli
dell'arte mai modo in cui la luce
colpisce la cattedrale
voi allora cosa fa raccoglie tutti gli
spiccioli che ha ottenuto dalle sue
mostre e affitta una stanzetta in un
hotel l'hotel bangla terre che si trova
proprio di fronte alla cattedrale di
dwan a questa piccola finestra che da
sulla cattedrale e ci si rinchiude non è
che ci passi poco tempo passa due anni
all'interno della stanzetta e dipinge
tante versioni della sua cattedrale
nel fare questo monet si comporta da
scienziato perché fa delle cose che sono
tipiche del metodo scientifico
osserva
trascrive e ripete
quello che vedete qui è un pezzo
dell'attività di monelli quegli anni
perché sono 12 cattedrali adesso solo
per fare un po un paragone ecco in un
laboratorio serio
normalmente si lavora così
non si lavora solo così si lavora anche
così però ma soprattutto si lavora così
in triple a ripetizione
se noi iniziamo con un esperimento lo
vogliamo rendere il più veritiero
possibile dobbiamo ripeterlo perché
altrimenti l'errore umano la casualità
possono portare ad avere dei risultati
non veritieri e quindi qua lavoriamo in
triplette lo vedete ripetuto uno due tre
volte
nei suoi due anni nella stanzetta
dell'hotel dong late a monet dipinge
31 tele
31 tele che ci danno proprio l'idea di
come il metodo che monet ha applicato in
realtà non abbia un sentimento dietro
non c'è il desiderio di riportare la
propria emozione in queste tele monet
vuole semplicemente trascrivere la luce
quella luce che l'ha colpito la prima
volta che ha visto la cattedrale
in realtà scienza e arte sono pieni di
questi crossover meravigliosi e vorrei
parlarvi in realtà di un altro esempio
che ama e colpisce sempre
capolavoro la notte stellata di van gogh
credo che forse la cosa più simbolica e
anche per rappresentativa di questo
quadro siano quei flussi di luce
che non si sa se van gogh ne fosse
propria conoscenza oppure no però se
analizzati a livello matematico
descrivono con una precisione
millimetrica la funzione di uno dei
concetti più complicati di tutta la
fluidodinamica e talmente tanto che non
riesco neanche a dire il nome è una
scoperta del genere dopo che anni anni
anni studiosi hanno analizzato la tela
di van gogh arriva senza sapere se van
gogh fosse a conoscenza di questo fatto
perché poi dipinge la tela mentre in
manicomio però secondo me è importante
avere esempi di questa creatività che si
fonde all'arte e alla scienza perché ci
dà un po un'idea di quello che sia un
vero artista
mi ci sono voluti quattro anni per
imparare a dipingere come raffaello ma
una vita intera per imparare a dipingere
come un bambino
è una frase attribuita a pablo picasso
che mi piace tantissimo perché dà l'idea
di quello che un artista debba fare per
diventare tale nella propria vita un
artista è innanzitutto un maestro
indiscusso non prende i colori e li
butta sulla tela un artista sa fare più
o meno qualsiasi cosa con la propria
arte con il proprio strumento e poi per
diventare grande per rimanere nella
storia deve fare qualcosa in più
un po come il jazz no in realtà sono
felicissima che ci siano dei film come
la la land sol perché ci hanno un po
allontanato da quell idea del jazzista
musica da ascensore ma il jazz piace da
morire e quello che mi piace del jazz è
proprio questo che il jazzista è un
artista certo un maestro indiscusso che
sa utilizzare il proprio strumento alla
perfezione e poi si lancia no fa
l'improvvisazione si coordina crea
qualcosa di unico con altre persone che
manco conosce a volte in un momento di
jazz
ora
giochetto l'abbiamo già fatto prove lo
ripeto lo stesso prima vi ho presentato
quello che secondo me era uno dei più
grandi artisti scusatemi uno dei più
grandi scienziati della storia l'artista
claude monet
adesso quello che vi voglio far vedere è
seriamente uno dei più grandi artisti o
meglio jazzisti della storia
charles darwin è uno dei padri della
biologia moderna è un uomo che io in
quanto studiosa di evoluzione di
genetica ammiro moltissimo ma nel 1831
quando darwin aveva poco più di
vent'anni ma è che fosse proprio un
prodigio aveva fallito gli studi di
teologia
stava fallendo gli studi di medicina
aveva una grandissima passione
per la natura per gli animali a cui si
dedicava con metodo scientifico in
continuazione a ripetizione
talmente tanto che a un certo punto
darwin si trova in una conversazione e
riesce a convincere mentre sto parlando
quello che poteva essere il pub
dell'epoca con un capitano un tale
fitzroy a imbarcarsi in una spedizione
che durerà cinque anni in quanto
naturalista di bordo
in quei cinque anni darwin fa un viaggio
incredibile chiaramente non finisce gli
studi di medicina si metterebbe però
scopre dei paradisi naturali fantastici
tra cui le isole galapagos delle
isolette che si trovano al largo delle
coste del sudamerica dalla parte
pacifica dove darwin trascorre cinque
settimane in solitudine
mentre la ciurma si diverte per altre
parti del sud america e il motivo per
cui darwin rimane lì così tanto tempo è
che proprio sulle isole galapagos ci
sono questi fringuelli li vedete e sono
tutti diversi fra di loro becco lungo
becco corto smussato chissà perché
affascinano così tanto darwin così tanto
che darwin inizia con il suo metodo
osservazione trascrizione ripetizione e
va avanti
però dopo un po
il cervello di darwin fa un qualcosa in
più
darwin è un cattolico molto credente
eppure guardando gli uccelli fringuelli
le loro forme e dimensioni
ci viene in mente qualcosa
a un certo punto si guarda attorno e
dice queste specie non le ha create dio
adesso io faccio anche un po fatica a
mettermi nei panni di un uomo
dell'ottocento che non ha molte certezze
nella vita però una eli è scritta sulla
bibbia dio fra il terzo e il sesto
giorno ha creato tutte le specie sulla
terra incluso l'uomo
ed erwin è un credente davvero davvero
fervente è un cattolico di professione
quasi lo stava per diventare eppure il
suo cervello non riesce a fermarsi lì
lui vede queste specie e la sua mente
non mette insieme i pezzi non è un
semplice maestro di base lui in questo
incredibile momento di jazz
crea con la propria testa qualcosa cui
nessuno aveva mai pensato prima di
allora
questa è l'essenza della creatività
tra le cose che darwin dice nella sua
prima scoperta
ci sono dei concetti che non piacciono
moltissimo all'epoca eppure lui è come
se le classi in maniera naturale come se
fossero più forti di lui perché le fa
così e le scarabocchia scrive hysen che
io penso e poi un albero genealogico mai
visto prima di allora però
scarabocchiate in 30 secondi delle note
a lato qualcosa di sotto in effetti non
dobbiamo neanche rimanere qui a leggere
però quello che darwin fa
sostanzialmente è creare la base della
teoria evoluzionistica in solitudine
sulle galapagos perché la sua mente non
riesce a smettere di creare
tra le cose che darwin dice poi ce n'è
una che suscita un po di scalpore e cioè
che
uomini e scimmie in particolare
scimpanzé gorilla condividono un
antenato comune
anche qui leggo dell'uomo a una bella
batosta perché pensare di non essere
stati creati da dio è una rivoluzione di
per sempre proprio a livello concettuale
però oggi sappiamo essere vera
con scimpanzé gorilla infatti
condividiamo il 98 per cento del nostro
dna tantissimo giusto per farvi un
paragone un altro mammifero il topo con
noi condivide il 67 per cento del
proprio dna quindi una differenza
abissale
in effetti se guardiamo il comportamento
di scimpanzé gorilla ci assomigliano
molto in tanti modi
c'è una differenza
è di nuovo torniamo sullo stesso tema la
creatività
certo possiamo dare un pennello in mano
a un gorilla uno scimpanzé a chiedere di
creare qualcosa e qualcosa verrà fuori
ma la grande differenza è che uno
scimpanzé a un gorilla non sentono la
necessità di trasmettere quella
creatività oltre non riescono a
concepire di creare qualcosa e lasciarla
generazioni future generazioni che non
esistono loro creano per la propria
socialità il proprio intorno o per se
stessi l'uomo no l'uomo ha qualcosa in
più in quel 2 per cento di dna che gli
consente di essere creativo
e sta tutto qui nel cervello circa 46
milioni di anni fa non siamo proprio
sicuri l'uomo inizia a divergere
rispetto alla sua iniziale con
formazione quindi da un antenato comune
inizia a distaccarsi diventa diverso si
evolve tra le evoluzioni che si
verificano c'è proprio questo aumento
della capacità del cranio quindi il
cervello diventa molto più grande e più
del doppio
però l'evoluzione funziona così in
maniera casuale come se una mattina mi
svegliassi con una vincita pazzesca la
lotteria decidesse di comprare una
ferrari e poi comprassi questa ferrari
solo per andare al mercato del mio paese
forse realizzata la cavolata un po
venderei la ferrari riprenderei soldi
che mi rimangono e li spenderei maniera
un po più intelligente l'evoluzione
uguale l'evoluzione fa qualcosa
aumentare la capacita cranica per
esempio però se poi non funziona se non
ha senso torna indietro
dice no non ha funzionato
ce ne liberiamo anche perché è un
cervello è dispendioso un cervello
consumo un sacco di zucchero perché
tenerlo lì se non serve ma gli è servito
un cervello più grande e probabilmente
anche altre specie hanno avuto momenti
in cui il cervello è diventato un po più
grande
ma per loro non è stato così utile
per gli umani si per questo per la
socialità noi umani rispetto a qualsiasi
altro mammifero in giro per il pianeta
abbiamo una caratteristica a milano
stare in gruppo amiamo le folle cosa che
il copy da reso un po più complicata
però il concetto di socialità
importantissimo perché attraverso gli
scambi attraverso il continuo contatto
con altri riusciamo a sviluppare quella
creatività
ecco
per dare un po di voce a questa teoria
che può sembrare forse solo un po
buttata lì ci sono in realtà degli
studiosi della julia hall di londra che
hanno creato un modello matematico per
descrivere come l'umanità abbia subito
cambiamenti demografici nel corso della
storia e hanno trovato un qualcosa di
molto interessante una correlazione fra
l'incremento demografico
e le scoperte più grandi della storia
dell'umanità cioè attraverso appunto gli
scheletri che sono stati rinvenuti i
resti archeologici hanno visto che ogni
volta che c'è stata una innovazione
incredibile per esempio la ruota o i
primi metalli appena prima c'era stato
un boom demografico
quindi un po il senso di quello che
voglio dire oggi parlando appunto di
scienza ma soprattutto di creatività e
che gli umani hanno sicuramente
una caratteristica in più rispetto a
tutte le altre specie appunto questa
abilità di essere creativi e io quando
penso alla scienza in realtà sono
profondamente grata di avere questo
elemento di creatività perché è proprio
grazie al momento di jazz di alcuni
grandi scienziati che arrivano le
scoperte più importanti della storia
dell'umanità la scienza quindi non
esisterebbe in un certo senso senza la
sua creatività
ma ancora più importante è questo è il
fatto che la creatività per esistere
perché rimanga abbia bisogno della
socialità e questo è ciò che davvero ci
rende una specie unica
grazie
[Applauso]